my name is larry yarn
i work here at the college that other
guy was whalen
he's like an english prof who gets his
his uh
pronouns wrong sometimes um
we have some distinguished p oh i i did
you like the choir
and that second piece uh
the choir director jim holloman who's a
meister
he knows that i like the scandinavian
composer the modern guy martin lowitz
lordson and that was one of his
and they're great and david made the
point these kids have about two hours a
week to practice
so they work hard so we have some
distinguished guests here
apart from our guest of honor and i'm
going to name some of them
first of all the how would you put it
the first man of the department of
education
is the great dick devos
he was almost elected governor of our
state
and god wouldn't have been better if he
had
secretary devos's mother elsa and her
husband rick
brookhausen brook heisen are here
and recognize them please
[Applause]
and uh her son and dick's son
rick devos and his wife melissa are here
are you the one who works at amway now
no
i keep wondering who's running that
place um
seems to be going great though okay we
have
other distinguished people we have the
senate majority leader mike shirkey is
here
and the education committed chairman of
the michigan senate
lana this is here that's it
where's she
hey good job she's been down here to
talk to me she's
pretty good uh kurt
wilder former member of the michigan
supreme court was supposed to be here
and because he couldn't make it because
he got canceled i get to tell
you before i tell him that the board of
trustees of the college
haven't voted unanimously to invite him
to become a member
and
and if you don't see his name on our
board of trustees list it means he's a
dirty dog
uh our local prosecutor is here
and he's been a great man for as long as
i've known him which is 20 years
but he's done some really great things
this summer and i'm not even going to
tell you what they are
but they're awesome neil brady please
stand up
he he gave the most eloquent speech at a
hillsdale academy
athletic banquet i've ever heard he
stands up and he says
he's a volunteer coach he says
i coach boys boys like wood
they like to hit things with it they
like to cut it
and they like to burn it that's what
boys are like
and then he was finished
it was a deep insight into human nature
right there
did that video make anybody think of
margaret thatcher
i've been privileged to know the
secretary for 20 years
she came here about three weeks after i
came to work here and
wanted me to support her voucher
initiative which i did
and i wondered that it might not work
because it's very hard to make those
work
but she just soldiered on
it's not despite you know of all the
colleges in america
we are the ones totally unbeholden to
the united states department of
education
[Applause]
we'll start taking its money six months
after they get rid of it
it's not uh despite but because of that
fact that i
admire our speaker tonight
we do not think here that education is
not a function
of government it isn't constitutionally
prescribed in the federal constitution
but right from the beginning they found
artful ways to support it
hugely 136 to the western land
starting with michigan right here and
then that was given as an endowment to
the states to
provide education in each township for
the purposes
of religion morality and knowledge being
necessary to good government and the
happiness of mankind so that means that
education is a hallowed thing in any
great
country and a concern of its govern
government
even if here it's to be run by the state
governments
but we've lost sight of what it is
because like everything else
it's run in a central way according to
bureaucratic rules
and that is destructive of the whole
phenomenon
the greatest fighter against that
that i have seen and i'm old now right
i've seen them all
is our speaker tonight she doesn't need
this
any of this
people you know any fair account of the
thing
would have to be this is a sacrifice for
her
that kind of public service today by the
way is like war
it's like taking casualties and
she volunteered for that now
has she done it it starts with the fact
that she's a mother and she has some
children
and she raised them some when i was here
tonight she watched them learn
she thought what's that about look how
that happens
then she was interested in schools of
course she was her kids are going to go
to school
she had the plain common sense to think
how would you organize the school
except in a way to tap the force of a
mother and a father's love
in the education of the child
isn't it barbarous that we lose sight of
that today
isn't that one of the grimmest signs of
the times
not her she's volunteered for everything
all her life she's
done heart duty when it comes to her
never complains
i've never seen her get angry although
i thought in that video you know the
things that have been done to her
they're just simply indecent right and
she's not scarred by them
in any way but she does seem mighty
ready to fight
she's done two things of great
imagination that i can
name one of them is
see you know all these ivy league
colleges
are apologizing that they are racist
institutions
you know which by the way is entirely
implausible
right does anybody ever meet racial
discrimination
at princeton you know at williams
college they can hardly have college
these days because the woke movement
disrupts classes and stalks people
and and students at williams college in
princeton
they chanted people you are killing me
with your whiteness whereas in fact
they're among the most privileged people
on earth
right and so you know come to find out
i didn't know it but because i don't do
that but
if you get the money from the federal
government you have to certify every
year that you're not a racist
institution
and so they made a public announcement
that they were
and she wrote him a letter and said wow
what about this
which of these two things is true that
was very embarrassing
i just when i heard that i went gosh
look at listen to that
i wish i had thought of that
the second thing is she wants to
implement
a federal tax credit she's going to talk
about that tonight she's talking about
whatever she wants to
but uh what that would be would be
for families to get part of their
federal
tax back for educating their kids as
they please
now i want to tell you what that's
parallel to and also i'll tell you i'm
shocked to discover that many
republicans
and many people in the conservative
movement can't see the truth of this
the device that was used in the land
ordinance of 1785
and in the northwest ordinance extended
all across the nation
and the device that was used in the in
the morel act signed by abraham lincoln
is the federal government has an asset
and it ought to delegate or or
delegate that asset to the states to let
them
do the great things that they're able
that they're
empowered to do education chief among
them right
and so the federal government has no
business
regulating education in detail but what
if it took part of its
great largesse which is way beyond any
right calculation of its needs and let
this
let the people have that
it would be spent in the states of
course because everybody lives in a
state
and let them choose and then you would
restore the connection
between a mother's love and the
education
of a child and the breaking of that
is the end of civilization is continues
and the best person i've seen qualified
to do something about that
is our speaker secretary of education
betsy devos
well good evening everyone before i
begin i want to just take one point of
personal privilege
and thank so many of my family members
for being here this evening
it is special indeed i don't get to have
them
with me that often and i'd also like to
apologize for the fact that you're going
to have to listen to
a second speech from me but
thank you so much dr arne for that very
kind introduction
thank you for your leadership here and
your unparalleled commitment
to the diffusion of sound learning
that line from hillsdale's charter is by
itself
a noble charge put in the context of
your
founding it becomes a higher calling
your founders believe then as we still
do today
that education is the means by which we
secure the god-given
blessings of liberty and under dr arn's
bold leadership
and clear-eyed vision hillsdale
continues to be a fertile oasis
for those who seek truth in higher
education
in a higher education landscape that
seems to be rapidly deserting it
hillsdale's founders welcomed anyone and
everyone who wanted to learn
with malice toward none with charity for
all
long before those words from abraham
lincoln
carried america's conscience your
charter was the first
in our history to prohibit any
discrimination on the basis of race
religion sex or any other label by which
governments divide us
from being an early force for abolition
to turning away the government's
regulators
to rejecting taxpayer subsidies
hillsdale's hallmark was is
and always will be independence
[Applause]
and let me add though i always admired
that independence
having been witness to the federal
bureaucracy at work for
nearly four years i can tell you with
certainty
your decision to decline any help from
washington was wise then
and it's still wise today
so earlier this afternoon i was pleased
to visit with some of you
and learn more about what you're doing
to rethink education
students are benefiting from a classical
approach to learning
and internalizing first principles from
the first texts of our framers
it's also encouraging that many
hillsdale graduates begin their careers
at the front of the classroom often in
schools launched as part of your charter
school initiative
from idaho to florida the initiative has
helped open more than 24 public charter
schools
serving more than 12 000 students
currently
more schools are slated to open soon and
they couldn't come at a more important
time
across america there's massive unmet
demand
especially right now the covid crisis
has laid bare
a lot about american education parents
are more aware than ever before
how and what their children are
or are not learning and far too many of
them are stuck with no choices
no help and no way forward
sadly too many politicians heed the
shrill voices of the education lobby
and ignore the voices of children
parents
teachers and health experts who are
begging to get our students back to
learning
as for me i fight for america's students
i fight for their parents and i fight
against anyone who would be have
government be the parent to everyone
now many in washington think because of
their power
there they can make decisions for
parents everywhere
in that troubling scenario the school
building replaces the home
the child becomes a pawn and the state
replaces the family that sequence has
played itself
out too many times throughout the course
of human history
my family has deep roots in holland the
netherlands
and i think of the debate that took
place there during much of the 18th and
19th centuries and beyond
in the interest of time i'm going to
truncate history a little bit
for a time parents in holland raise
their children according to their
customs and their beliefs
with little supervision from the
government or its schools
but the french revolution brought with
it the idea of a one-size-fits-all
school system
one that the dutch were arguably too
quick to adopt
over time the view that education was a
responsibility of government
not of parents grew to prevail among
dutch elites
independent schools were illegal parents
had no options
and no hope until they met
abraham kuiper this pastor turned
politician became a rousing voice for
parents
who were not happy with their government
one which
claimed the right to set up the school
for all children
a system that kuiper said summons their
children from their homes
yet increasingly erases every
distinctive feature of families
and provides uniform guidance to every
child
kuiper asserted that the way forward was
to separate education
from partisan politics he said that the
family
the business science art and so forth
are all social spheres which do not owe
their existence to the state
and which do not derive the law of their
life from
the state and so kuiper argued
the state cannot intrude into these
spheres
and has nothing to command in their
domain
he made very clear the education of
children
is within the family sphere so parents
are called
to determine the school the choice of
school
for their children for most of his
political career kuiper was a voice for
parents
and a fierce defender of the family
a few years before his death dutch
families won a constitutional amendment
in 1917 which gave children's futures
back to parents and today more than a
century later
they are in control of their education
dollars to pay for their kids to attend
the schools
of their choosing let me suggest
we could fix education for so many
children in america
if we to borrow an old phrase
go dutch
that means we embrace the family as the
sovereign sphere that it is
a sphere that predates government
altogether
it's been said after all that the family
is not only an institution
it's also the foundation for all other
institutions
the nuclear family cultivates art
athletics
business education faith music
film in a word culture
and just as the family shapes its
culture it also shapes its government
that truth is contained in our founding
here we the people govern
because we know what's best for
ourselves and for our children
and we consent to a government that
exercises
only those duties we delegate to it
our schools exist because we pay for
them so we should be empowered to spend
our education dollars
our way on our kids i like to picture
kids with their backpacks
representing funding for their education
following them
wherever they go to learn in this sense
public and private schools alike don't
exist to supplant parents
they exist to supplement them now some
claim this would cost too much
but like so many arguments put forward
in this debate
the facts just don't bear that out every
year
american taxpayers spend about 739
billion dollars
that's billion with a b on government
education
more than fifteen thousand dollars on
average
per student per year and
spending increases year after year
after year now i can imagine what you're
thinking
i could educate my child for fifteen
thousand dollars per year
i'm told your academy here at hillsdale
charges less than half that much
you could improve your child's outcome
with that kind of money
a single parent in detroit or flint or
grand rapids could open the door to a
better life for their child
if only they had control of how
taxpayers
dollars are used and spent on their
child's education
america's parents agree there's a mighty
chorus
and it's rising in volume and urgency
supporting parental school choice
countless surveys show that more
families today
want parental choice than ever before
a recent clear real clear opinion survey
found that three out of four families
with children in public schools
want their education dollars to follow
their children wherever they go to learn
notably 73 percent of black families and
71 percent of hispanic families say they
want the same
thing so school choice is not a matter
of if
it's a matter of when fortunately
when is now for some students in arizona
florida north carolina and even illinois
who today have more choices than they
did four years ago
but we're just getting started i've
spent more than half my life alongside
you
fighting to resurrect the rights of
parents in education
more than 30 years of time and treasure
devoted to giving all kids
the same opportunities my own kids had
in fact i've been working to reform
education since
soon after jimmy carter bent to the
demands of big union bosses
and created the department i had today
now i assume most of you have never
stepped foot inside the u.s department
of education
and i can report you haven't missed much
these past few years i've gotten a
close-up view
of what that building focuses on and let
me tell you
it's not on students it's on rules and
regulations
staff and standards spending and spring
strings on protecting the system
forty years later taxpayers have spent
more than
one trillion dollars at the federal
level alone
trying to fix k-12 education
the results speak for themselves
just open up the nation's report card
and you'll see what i mean
america's gold standard assessment of
academic achievement reports
the appalling result that two-thirds of
our nation's students
can't read like they should two out of
three
now those are just some numbers but
behind the statistics are real
consequences
for real people put yourself in the
shoes of the father
whose son a recent high school graduate
was honored in the local newspaper
dad's pride turns to dismay as he
discovers his son
can't read or comprehend the article
about himself
dad marches over to the high school
principal's office his son and the
newspaper in tow
and asks his son to read the article to
the principal
he of course can't the father pointedly
asks the principal
how he could have graduated his
graduated his son
or anyone else who can't read
there is no defensible answer
i think of my visit to an indianapolis
prison
the warden shared with me that the
biggest problem there is not
violence nor discipline it's illiteracy
these are very real consequences of
government overreach into every part of
our lives
when i took on this role i said from day
one that i'd like to work myself out of
a job that i'd like to
that i'd work to empower parents not
politicians
to that end we restored state
local and family control of education by
faithfully implementing the every
student succeeds act
by ending common core and by urging
congress to put an end to education
earmarks by consolidating nearly
all fake federal k-12 programs
into one block grant we expanded the
in-demand
dc voucher program by 50 percent we
supported the creation of more public
charter schools
with a particular focus on opportunity
zones
70 percent of which currently have no
public charter
schools we reform the tax code so
families can use
tax preferred 529 savings accounts for
expenses related to k-12 education
we joined montana parents in their fight
all the way to the supreme court
ending the last acceptable prejudice
made manifest in bigoted plane
amendments
which deny students the freedom to
pursue faith-based education
and we support the bipartisan school
choice now act
which would directly fund families and
empower them to choose the best
educational setting for their children
a majority in the united states senate
voted in favor of senator tim scott's
school choice now provision
i think you all know senator scott and
his story
his life experience demonstrates how
education
can change lives he said his mother knew
that
if we could find the opportunity bigger
things would come
and for students like him who by no
fault of their own
are denied opportunities he knows
firsthand that students need access to
more of them
right now families could use these
scholarships to enhance distance
learning
or to pay for other costs tied to
educating children at home
they could be used for tutoring career
and technical education
or transportation to a different school
the scholarships could support students
attending the school that best meets
their needs
or matches their values at the end of
the day
we want parents to have the freedom the
choices and the funds
to make the best decisions for their
children
the washington knows best crowd really
loses their minds over that
they seem to think that the people's
money
doesn't belong to the people that it
instead belongs to
the public or rather what they really
mean
government winston churchill pointed out
the danger in missing the difference
he said there's a kind of voluntary
socialism that says
all mine is yours but the kind of
socialism government forces says
all yours is mine too many today
especially among our rising generation
don't
seem to understand the dangers of such a
view
they somehow have come to believe that
socialism is the cure
not the deadly disease it really is
tragically it's because no one has
taught them differently
and worse some have been indoctrinated
to believe not in themselves
but in government we know more than half
of today's high school seniors have what
researchers call a below basic knowledge
of american history
in the real world that means more than
half of our young men and women
don't know what the lincoln douglas
debates were about
they can't identify that a photo labeled
berlin 1989
depicts the fall of the berlin wall nor
do they understand the significance of
those momentous events
and it's not just history we've failed
to teach them
america's cities ablaze today witness a
failure to teach the things that make
the american experiment work
it's ignorant to hate capitalism when
you don't really know how communism
hasn't worked
it's ignorant to hate freedom when you
don't really know
how tyranny hasn't worked so the unholy
mob
thinks our economies need redistributing
it thinks our constitution needs
rewriting
it thinks our families need
restructuring
one prominent group was explicit
explicit about its desire to
quote disrupt the western prescribed
nuclear family structure
that's taken right from the old marxist
playbook
it admits the goal is to quote do away
with private property
and educate children on a communal basis
and in this way remove the two bases of
traditional marriage
end quote mercifully
even marxists know the family is it
the family is at the center of our
economy of education
of culture and it's under attack today
recall what's being said about judge amy
coney barrett's
big family as if raising seven children
is something to be embarrassed by or
worse
ashamed of perhaps that comes from a
small minded
and offensive view that american women
cannot be devoted to their families
be smart hard-working faithful
independent successful
and be conservative what we know to be
true
what we know to be true is that women
can be
all of those things so tonight
let's proclaim with one voice that
dogma lives loudly within all of us
[Applause]
g k chesterton warned that the triangle
of truisms
of father mother and child cannot be
destroyed
it can only destroy those civilizations
which
disregard it some however suggest we
should simply throw in the towel and
accept what is
at the expense of what could be these
folks
cower at the crowds lament legislative
losses
despair over court decisions and
resignedly say
this is the new normal they tell the
rest of us to accept
that we really are living in a
culturally post-christian nation
that we'd be that we'd best retreat to a
makeshift monastery
and leave culture and country behind
others feel forced into a self-imposed
silence
because what was once the beginning of
discourse
is now the end of acceptance
cancel culture has invaded the workplace
the neighborhood and friendships
in today's modern town squares facebook
twitter and the like one can't publicly
express
a conservative view without inviting
scathing rebuke
or worse censorship ronald reagan warned
this would happen when he so presciently
predicted that if fascism ever comes to
america
it'll come in the name of liberalism
after all haven't we watched those who
talk tolerance turn around and behave
like some of the most intolerant people
on earth
to be sure this environment makes it
harder to protect principle
to defend what t.s eliot called the
permanent things
hillsdale's great friend russell kirk
famously enumerated a few of them
charity justice duty
fortitude and freedom
we need those permanent things now more
than ever
and they require our defense now more
than ever
this was true in abraham kuiper's day as
well
dutch families were concerned about
government control and cultural decay
then
as we are today many there also called
for a retreat
but kuiper called an isolationist
impulse
the grand lie he asserted that we each
have a calling in the midst
of the life of the world and that we
cannot neglect
the world importantly he reminded us
that
the school is one of the chief
instruments precisely for
enriching people ultimately kuiper said
that arrows do not exist simply to be
kept in the quiver
at some point they need to be placed on
the bowstring
now i know some might shrink from that
metaphor
but the moms in this room know what i
mean
we know what to do with an arrow when
our family is under attack
so instead of canceling the culture
let's answer kuiper's call
to challenge the culture with education
instead of rewriting our constitution
let's return to its timeless words
and restore the power of we the people
because we don't believe in retreat
we believe in redemption let's begin by
reasserting this fundamental truth
the family is the first school
if we recognize that then we must also
reorder everything
about education around what the family
wants
and what the family needs
make no mistake america cannot win the
future
if we lose the rising generation
if we get the family and its freedom
right
everything else that's wrong about our
culture
will write itself rebuild the family
restore its power and we will reclaim
everything right about america and
us so as our founding fathers did long
ago
let us pledge our sacred honor to
rediscover and resurrect
all that makes us great we are families
education is our sovereign sphere
and we are taking it back thank you for
keeping hillsdale a fountain of ideas
for
america and her students thank you very
much
you